[Music]
what did you learn about risk at a
whorehouse it's a very risky job
especially if you're working in the
illegal market there's always a risk
that your client could be the police or
just a deranged lunatic who will kill
you
Allison Schrager is the author of an
economist walks into a brothel
a fascinating dive into how different
communities assess risk and what we can
learn from them including sex workers at
the Moonlite bunnyranch in Nevada
I went to the brothel to see how that
legal market manages risk because the
legal market provides a fairly risk free
space to do sex work where the women
have security we don't worry about
screening their clients and they go
through thorough background checks and
disease screenings and have a lot of
support their risk is minimized and then
also the risk for the jobs is also
minimize exactly and that's actually
it's sort of an interesting play on pimp
I guess Dennis HOF when he was alive
loved sort of reclaiming the expression
pimp so I think of a pimp I think of
this guy who's pushing these women into
these very dangerous situations and then
taking all the money so we call that in
finance like an in a none sensible risk
you generally in finance people who take
more risk or supposed to get more reward
and you know a market isn't functioning
properly when the people who take the
biggest risks don't get the biggest
reward which happens often in crime
because there's sort of messed up
markets for a lot of reasons so what's
interesting about what Dennis does is he
actually makes his spread you know what
the John's play and what the women have
to pay to minimize the risk of reduce
risk for everyone involved in the
transaction he is sort of a pioneer in
the world of sex work he was running
some sort of business with timeshares
and just had a lot of friends in the
porn industry and spent time in brothels
and had this idea that you could
approach sex work the way you approach
timeshares it's like a total ripoff is
what you're I think it's a fair
transaction you know you're not locked
in like you out were that I'm sure
you're not stuck seeing these sex
workers year after year and it's not
like you have to then sell your time
with them somewhere else but the idea is
that you are effectively renting someone
or renting a service I guess it's a
nicer way to think about it Nevada has a
long history with legal sex work before
you know they were kind of dingy sort of
depressing places they don't like luxury
spas the women they
were you know having to be there for
hours or days at a time where they
weren't allowed to leave there are set
prices they had to they had no control
over who they were servicing so with
this idea that he was going to make them
all independent businesswoman and that
they would negotiate every transaction
on their own terms only have sex with
people they wanted to and set the prices
themselves to meet with the world's most
interesting risk takers shraeger
traveled the country to study horse
breeders military commanders
professional poker players in Hollywood
paparazzi on Hawaii's North Shore she
found herself attending the annual big
wave risk assessment safety summit where
she found that surfers and financial
risk advisors have a lot in common their
leader is this guy named Brian Carlotta
who had this idea that risk is something
that could be managed which is the whole
ethos of financial economics so he had
the same idea and he's been studying
risk science with the military and had
this idea that they would regularly have
these summits where they were discussed
risk science but for big wave surfers
and they really discuss a lot of the
same things we do in pension conferences
different ways you can minimize risk
manage risk take risk and smarter ways
for instance waves travel and sets so
you like big waves will run in a pack of
five in finance we'd call this a hedge
which is taking less risk but still
getting some reward in sort of
calibrating it or so so you never want
to take an early wave in a set because
if you wipeout they'll be four or five
large waves barreling on you so you want
to do is take a wave in the fourth or
fifth set anyway that might be a smaller
wave just so you have less risks they
talk about things like that these guys
are not necessarily adrenaline junkies
or they they what they do is risky but
they're not big risk takers no in fact
there's almost something very
intellectual about the way they take
risk it's you know I was talking to Greg
long who's a very well-known big wave
surfer about him it's almost this
intellectual endeavor of here's this
huge force of matter how can I do this
in a very intellectual way and minimize
the risk and still be able to do this
activity the markets that are working
well in your book are kind of they're
free and open where a lot of different
participants you know kind of work
through things and certain norms get
kind of inscribed I mean on the one hand
that means when people from outside
industry come in and say like you guys
are doing it all wrong I'm gonna bring
you know my you know my outsider
knowledge to bear on this they typically
don't work very well or it doesn't last
very long but then also regulators often
come in and figure they contain a market
is is there something going on there
about risk that regulators and kind of
neophytes both dismiss yeah for sure and
I mean I did that too because I would go
into these markets I don't have any
expertise in surfing or horse breeding
and I would always come in with all this
is how we do it in finance have you
thought about doing options on studs and
everyone's always like no of course not
this is not how it works and of course
they were always right but the right the
regulation is hard because every
community has this very strong
libertarian streak with the big
discussion at the big wave surf
conference was about a systemic risk a
systemic risk is that you take you're a
big institution you take a big risk and
you bring down the whole system so this
is the big debate and big wave surfing
is the you know as technology jet skis
or inflatable vests encourage people to
take on more risk and that diverts
rescue resources to other people or you
have people in water crashing into other
people or you know it's a it's a safety
risk of people have to rescue them so
it's in a sense of systemic risk and so
they're constantly debating who should
be able to buy safety equipment and you
know who should be surfing big waves and
I was like well you know we have these
discussions and pension conferences and
it sounds like you're asking for some
level of regulation you know how you
know should you be like asks I'm like
people shouldn't be licensed to be a big
wave surfer like the same way you're
licensed to be a scuba diver and this is
they say like they're all pretty liberal
about most things they're like other big
wave this is the inflatable vest company
that sells vests to anyone which they
find very offensive because it means
more risk for everyone they're just
about the money but once I was like well
do you think you should be regulated do
you think big wave surfing should be
licensed they're like no no we need to
keep the government out of big wave
surfing they were very emphatic about
that what is the big takeaway that you
because the book is also on a certain
level as a self-help book or you know or
a personal finance book yeah personal
finance gets a bad rap you know
especially in academic finance but I
think it's a bigger message than just
personal finance which is that people
should feel more comfortable taking
risks we don't really give people the
tools
to feel comfortable with risk-taking but
you really do need to take risks to make
your life move forward and any aspect to
your life if it's a relationship if it's
your job anything is to help people
understand that there is a way of taking
risk where they can do stuff to protect
themselves if things go wrong there
aren't any guarantees but they can
definitely increase the odds things work
out for them
[Music]